patching.
See, it throws in there.
That's it. It throws in there. If I do I
do no more than swapping over.
It needs very little power cuz what he
does is he's actually the one going,
"Oh, I shouldn't have done that." cuz
he's so he throws his own balance
off balance.
He's thinking, "Yeah, I think I can
still get his leg." But what he doesn't
realize is what he doesn't realize is
I'm already going well before
I just want to clear that up. I can read
his mind.
What I do is at my length I just drop
this real quick there. see them
before he before he's even got in the
full cat. I don't want to give you too
much away
but that point there
of
that
is
the same point in the nagging
[Applause]
the same point in the kagi. All these
things take time. But as here, if you
come here, right, he's he's comfortable,
isn't he? You know what I mean? He's
there. He's locked, but he's locked. So,
if he tries to come up, he shouldn't
come up. But your aim eventually is to
have now the projection of extension
mind
breath position.
So what I'm going to do now is I'm going
to put my mind breath
on
this projection. So when he comes up,
he's got that feeling
that feeling of the only escape route is
that way. He knows that the escape route
is up. So here it's up and I can push
down. He doesn't actually see this
escape route.
See, there's no escape route there, is
there?
>> No.
So I've got to make him and me feel that
that is the way and it has to be before
this knee comes in.
I've already shown you that this is
important. If you go from here to here,
you've missed that face there.
See here there. See, he doesn't think of
coming up. What he thinks of you got
lovely extension in his shoulder, but
that doesn't bother me cuz this is the
only clear route for him to go to. Then
when you add the knee, he goes away.
Hopefully Ind.